new at six for the first time we're
getting an inside look at what it's like
being in mtv
being an emt excuse me during the
pandemic
today hundreds of first responders
across the valley receive the first dose
of their cobot vaccine
the i-team's david charns is live in
henderson with more on how coronavirus
is affecting emergency response david
well kirsten outside station 84 here in
henderson
firefighters here will be about among
the first
thousand employees in the city here of
first responders to get the vaccine
they're part of that first
tier meantime this all comes as the
i-team has learned that
calls to 9-1-1 about medical emergencies
that kind of stuff
is down about 30 percent but emt's told
me today there is no reason to worry
[Music]
being able to get to this point is truly
a
change in that tide so to speak it's the
first dose of hope
in henderson these are people that put
themselves in danger
every day hundreds of police officers
firefighters and emts in the city
getting that first dose of the covet
vaccine all here at community ambulance
the opportunity to be able to provide
some type of
vaccination to them to provide clarity
for not only themselves but their family
is
is important glenn simpson of community
ambulance was one of the first to get
his shot
he says covid has changed the way his
team responds to a call
every time you call 9-1-1 your call is
being screened
and if you scream positive for kovid we
do that so that we can alert our
responders so that when they arrive they
can
already take additional steps to protect
themselves as well as the patient
he tells the i-team the number of people
calling 9-1-1
is down by as much as 30 percent since
the start of the pandemic
not because people aren't sick but fewer
tourists are in town
and whether that's because they're
worried about
catching covet in the back of the
ambulance or catching covet at the
hospital
he says it is safe ambulances are
sanitized and put through an additional
uv light process
with more protection these first
responders will be able to get the
vaccine out to the rest of us
being able now to administer vaccines to
to our own
and eventually other tier groups is
certainly it's part of why we get into
this business
and we can't stress it enough during an
emergency call 9-1-1
even if you're worried about covid i
just showed you those precautions and
they are in place no matter if you're in
henderson
or other parts of the valley henderson
will continue
vaccinating all its first responders
although a thousand of them
through the rest of the week we're live
in henderson tonight i'm david charns 8
news now